بعد اكثر من اربعه اشهر من الاحتجاجات
المتاعب التي يواجهها النظام الايراني
تتفاقم تسجيل صوتي جديد للمساعد السابق
لمؤسسه الرئاسه الايرانيه بحكومه روحاني
محمد رضا صالحي وفي اجتماع المحافظين
الاخير كشف مخاوف من الانهيار الداخلي
للنظام مطالبا بتحديد صلاحيات خامنائي بما
في ذلك بند الولايه المطلقه
يجب توجيه المرشد بخصوص الظروف الحاليه
والمستقبليه للبلاد المرشد يبلغ من العمر
نحو 80 عاما حتى لو عاش بعد 100 عام اخرى
هناك نهايه من سيجرا على اجراء الاستفتاء
ستتعطل العديد من قوانيننا وهي معطله الان
من الضروري تقويه البعد الاشرافي للقياده
وتقليص نطاق صلاحياته التنفيذيه من
الضروري تعديل الدستور على اساس تقويه
اركان الجمهوريه وتعزيز حق الشعب في
السياده من خلال الانتخابات وزياده
صلاحيات المؤسسات والمنتخبين والخاضعين
للمساءله في اثناء ذلك الاحتجاجات في كل
المناطق لا تهدا ففي ابضنان بمحافظه ايلام
غربا رفع المحتجون شعار الموت للديكتاتور
واغلقوا الشوارع باشعال النار ليلا وفي
محافظه اصفهان ايضا ردد المحتجون شعارات
مناوئه للنظام ليلا قابلت ذلك حمله
اعتقالات واسعه شامله نطاقها كل جغرافيا
البلاد ما لا يقل عن
367 مواطنا بلوشيا وكرديا تم اعتقالهم من
قبل قوات الامن الايرانيه خلال شهر يناير
المحاكمات هي الاخرى لا تتوقف 14 محتجا
تمت احالتهم على المحكمه بتهم قتل عنصر من
الباسج في طهران ويواجهون احكاما قد
تقودهم الى حبل المشنقه بلال البشتين
العربيه